هو بالتاكيد بريطانيا ليست وحدها في حاله
الغضب العارم مما تقوم به ايران ونظامها
بما يخص التظاهرات هناك من يلوح برد فعل
اكبر واضخم يا طاهر اذن بريطانيا طبقه
وشين او ادنى من المضيق قدما في خطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه فاعدام اكبر غير
الموازين لكنه امر البرنامج النووي
بالنسبه لاسرائيل شبه محسوم ربما لانها
بكل الاحوال تنظر اليه على انه اكبر تهديد
محتمل اقليميا وعالميا وعليه فان رئيس
اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي المنتهيه ولايته
الجنرالذيذ كخافي قال ان بلاده مستعده
لمهاجمه المنشات النوويه الايرانيه حتى
بلا مساعده الولايات المتحده مضيفا ان
العوده الى خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه
يمكن ان تمنح النظام الايراني الفرصه
لتحقيق اول قنبله نوويه في غضون اسابيع
قليله مع تخصيب كافن لليورانيوم واردفه
مؤكدا ان اسرائيل تملك مقرا كاملا يركز
على انشاء خطط عملياتيه لمهمه مهاجمه
المنشات وانها بدات بالفعل بتدريبات
روتينيه في الاشهر السته الماضيه
وقبل يوم واحد من انتهاء ولايته ادلب كل
هذه التصريحات بل انه زاد عليها ان
اسرائيل باتت رهن اشاره القياده لتدمير
المواقع الايرانيه قائلا ان بنك الاهداف
في ايران قد اتسع خبر يتضافروا مع ما
اعلنه رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو قبل
نحو اسبوع عن ان اولويه حكومته تصدي
للنووي الايرانيه قائلا ان تل ابيب ستعمل
بصوره قويه وعلانيه على المستوى الدولي ضد
العوده الى الاتفاق النووي وليس فقط خلف
ابواب مغلقه
[موسيقى]
لكن يبدو ان تل ابيب حاولت امتصاص حديث
كخافي اذ قال مصدر عسكري اسرائيلي قال ان
خطه بلاده لشنه هجوم مستقل على منشات
ايران النوويه ليست جاهزه بعد ولكن قد
يتغير الوضع في حال استقبل الجيش اوامر من
المستوى السياسي
العسكري ان الجيش الاسرائيلي سيواصل
التجهيز لضربه عسكريه لايران عبر شراء
مقاتلات وذخائر خاصه ثم ذكر باهميه
الغارات الاسرائيليه على سوريا وذكر
بدورها في تعطيل موضوع ايران العسكري بحسب
وصفه اوكرانيا
ايران بتفعيل المسيارات في اوكرانيا
ولديها حلول لمواجهه هذه القدرات